[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à chaux-neuve
dimanche en politique spéciale ce matin
nous avons installé nos caméras au pied
du grand tremplin sur la zone de départ
de cette manche de coupe du monde de
combiné nordique à un événement
d'ampleur internationale évidemment
emblématique pour notre massif jurassien
un massif qui des ans néanmoins doit
faire face à des températures de moins
en moins hivernale des chutes de neige
de moins en moins abondantes
alors comment le jura s'adapte-t-il au
réchauffement climatique on veut en
débattre avec nos quatre invités ici je
voulais présente tout de suite d'abord
olivier est rare directeur de la station
de métabief grande station de ski du
haut doubs également sur ce plateau
improvisé
jean sébastien lacroix président de la
sogestar la société de gestion de la
station des rousses où vous êtes dans le
jura également avec nos pires albert van
damne le patron de la transjurassienne
président de la transe organisation et
anthony poulin élus écologistes bisontin
originaire du haut doubs bonjour à tous
les quatre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors vous en avez l'habitude cette
émission vous pouvez la commenter en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
modeste qui s'affiche dit mme paul fc
comme dimanche en politique franche
comté et puis je me ferais le relais de
vos questions tout au long de cette
émission tout au long du débat alors
messieurs le réchauffement climatique
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquer
comment vous en prenez compte dans vos
métiers respectifs
olivier rares à métabief est ce que
c'est une donnée qu'on prend en compte
aujourd'hui au quotidien
oui ça fait partie intégrante de nos de
nos méthodes de nos métiers on est par
nature
soumis aux aléas météorologiques donc on
a deux points certaine résilience et on
va faire tout le travail qu'il faut pour
l'année on reste dépendant de cette
météo et ça fait partie de notre adn
et alors ça se traduit comment dans les
faits ça se traduit par de
l'appréhension de savoir si on aura du
froid pour faire de la neige de culture
et de l'année jeu naturel et puis après
c'est de travailler le produit le
produit neige le mieux possible d'en
être le plus le plus gardiens de la
qualité mais vous vivez ça comme un défi
au fur et à mesure des ibères non je
crois qu'au fur et à mesure d hiver ou
de l'expérience on vit ça de manière
très philosophe on apprend c'est un
métier d'humilité et puis finalement
c'est dans notre culture donc ça n'a
rien de traumatisant de dramatique jean
sébastien lacroix même question vous aux
rousses à quelques km de métabief
la donne est la même l'enjeu est le même
bien sûr on a tout à fait de la même
problématique donc effectivement on doit
pas liés à ce réchauffement climatique
après on a déjà des pistes de travail
ont fait des en prime une préparation
peas qui est bien plus affinée que ce
qui se faisait avant et de cours on a
besoin également de moins ds pour
pouvoir ouvrir de remontées mécaniques
et puis on a toujours bien sûr un appui
dans les yeux culture même si on en fait
vraiment je dirais
sans forcer la dose parce qu'on est
vraiment très vigilant sur la ressource
en eau effectivement c'est voilà c'est
on s'adapte un techniquement également
ou russes moment climatique et ont pâli
un petit peu à ce manque de neige par
des part des nouvelles techniques en
fait mais sans neige de culture
aujourd'hui nos stations du massif
jurassien ne fonctionnerait pas ou
fonctionnerait très différemment
après c'est sur l'amplitude d'ouverture
on laisserait d'avoir une petite voiture
qui serait un peu moindre il n'empêche
que honda on est un peu dans une période
où en optimisent un petit peu nos
domaines skiables en utilisant vraiment
les partis qui sont les mieux exposés et
qui tiennent de mu la neige donc même
avec le neige en a ri toujours à ouvrir
une partie de l'hiver la neige de
culture effectivement c'est un apport
quittait qu'on arrive à avoir plus
d'amplitude sur le son aux ouvertures
pierre-albert wendel vous êtes le patron
de la transjurassienne qui va dans trois
semaines fêtait ses 40 ans ça fait 40
ans que la course tentent de traverser
avec plus ou moins de bonheur le massif
jurassien alors il ya eu d'ailleurs la
première année elle a été annulée faute
de neige donc c'est pour ça que c'est
pas d'actualité à 40 ans à la première
édition ce sont 19 et nuls et donc on se
retrouve sur ces mêmes problématiques
quelquefois lé manque de neige qui nous
perturbent et qui nous inquiète tous
mais bon on est toujours optimiste et
ont fait au premier mesure nécessaire
pour qu'on puisse nous relier le doubs
jura puisque c'est notre objectif et le
réchauffement climatique c'est une
réalité je veux dire ça se ressent c'est
quand même il ya toujours eu des hivers
avec plus ou moins de neige mais de
manière sur le long terme vous sentez
que c'est de plus en plus compliqué
notre progrès à tiko à 75 km de pistes
entretenir et puis la neige est tombée
là alors contre la beaucoup d'eux
d'endroits où c'est des zones humides et
il ya beaucoup de précipitations
pluvieuses qui durent pendant pendant
une semaine maintenant qu'on n'avait pas
il ya quelques années et qui qui
perturbe beaucoup parce que ça ça limite
le manteau neigeux et ça le salon
inutilisables ce que vous dites c'est le
problème ce n'est pas tant le manque de
neige que plus depuis un peu pour nous
hisser la pluie c'est le pli
l'angoissent vaut aujourd'hui la neige
elle est là elle est là sur notre
parcours par contre on sait que si on
part sur un épisode pluvieux que
maintenant que plus personne ne maîtrise
elle ça peut complètement
mettre à mal notre notre piste et puis
nous obliger à revoir notre lent par
rapport à ça anthony poulin vous vous
êtes écologiste est ce que la manière
dont le massif s'adapte au réchauffement
climatique on vient dans 23
professionnels vous satisfait pas
pleinement en tout cas pas pleinement
dans la façon dont les stations de
s'adapte si c'est pour produire de la
neige industriellement avec des canons à
neige en tant qu'écologiste ça ne me
convient pas par exemple on a vu la
station de métabief récemment et on
avait pris position sur cette question
produire de la neige alors même qu' il y
avait de la restriction d'eau dans tout
dans tout le département les retenues
collinaires pour nous c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui la réalité du réchauffement
climatique elle est là dans le massif
jurassien
les données sont l'un par exemple dans
les tourbières defrasne ces deux des
clés de plus en 10 ans la l'érosion de
la biodiversité c'est une réalité
combien de grands et ras aujourd'hui
dans la forêt du risoux par rapport à ce
qu'il était il ya cinquante ans on le
voit dans nos territoires nous avons
vraiment le réchauffement climatique
beaucoup moins de neige on estime il me
semble que chaque année on perd un jour
de neige est à peu près 1 cm de neige
par an en trente ans on a perdu 30 jours
de neige une partie de la saison un
quart de la saison qu'est ce qu'on fait
demain alors moi les chiffres que j'ai
qui m'ont été fournies par météo france
et qu' il ya quelques années on était à
deux mois et demi d'engagement sur le
massif jurassien à peu près autour de
1000 m on va dire aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt de moi oui voilà en très peu de
temps réalité l'a fallu de toute façon
que les acteurs sa date mais aujourd'hui
la question qui se pose à nous est de
savoir est-ce qu'on va et on prend un
autre virage totalement sur le tourisme
on se dit que le produit comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure le produit neige
n'est plus forcément le seul à vendre y
compris en hiver ou est ce qu'on
continue et on sera de plus en plus
devant au pied du mur et les acteurs du
territoire les emplois seront là pour le
coup vraiment menacés soit on anticipe
et on sauve des emplois soit on fait
différemment et
on sera face à des grandes difficultés
dans quelques années
olivier rare je vous laisse répondre oui
alors c'est tout à son une problématique
qui intéresse effectivement les acteurs
du territoire les élus au président
philippe alpy le président la communauté
de communes jean marie saillard avec qui
on travaille on a encore travaillé ce
matin sur les grandes orientations qu'on
doit donner à la
à notre un autre avenir on a une
obligation de pivoter depuis voter vert
vers quelque chose vers un produit qui à
terme quand on voit les modèles
climatiques aujourd'hui on a des niveaux
définition qui sont assez bons on a on a
20 ans de métabief c'est un peu c'est ça
qui se prépare donc qu'est-ce qu'on
commet pros ont fait ce pivotement la
principale
règle c'est de s'appuyer sur les
professionnels à ceux souvent eux qui
vont changer venu parler effectivement
de l'évolution des métiers de l'emploi
c'est ça qui est en jeu on est tous
d'accord excusez moi je reviens sur ce
que vous voulez dire donné que venait
d'apporter on a vingt ans devant nous
c'est à dire que dans 20 ans on peut
plus qui en franche comté nous on parle
on a tendance à croire ce modèle qui
nous qui nous est donné en tout cas en
ce printemps pour faire quoi sert dans
20 ans il y aura plus de neige sur les
pistes à métabief sait pas qu'il y aura
plus de neige se serait c'est tout là
c'est toute la difficulté c'est pas
linéaire c'est absolument pas linéaire
donc c'est très variable
aujourd'hui on a d'énormes variabilité
entre les deux derniers hivers qui se
sont passées et puis cet hiver la fin
voilà on a gardé renier c'était bon on
va pas mauvais d'ailleurs vous avez
mauvais mais le mois de janvier vous
veniez à la même date vous aviez vous
aviez de la flotte elysées il faisait
doux donc on est il n'y a pas un hiver
qui ressemble à un autre
ce qui est sûr qu'il ya une tendance au
réchauffement ont depuis 30 ans
effectivement il ya eu il ya une période
des années 80 qui était faste ça tombait
bien c'était le développement du ski il
ya eu il ya eu un an des genres assez
fort assez exceptionnel qui était même
supérieure à aux années 60 est là depuis
la fin des années 80 ce effectivement la
température moyenne a augmenté
là on est à un espèce de carrefour on se
dit est ce que en fonction des des choix
internationaux qui vont être faits sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
soit on va continuer à décoller à partir
de 2040 soit soit on en arrive à
stabiliser un peu et nous ça nous laisse
ça nous laisse un peu de souffle anthony
poulin les choix internationaux ils sont
déjà faits on est engagée la france à
réduire nos émissions nous sommes dans
cette trajectoire et la demande des
citoyens elle est très forte cette
question là il vient d'avoir une
pétition de 2 millions de personnes qui
soutiennent le recours des associations
contre l'état pour une action climatique
donc à une vraie demande citoyenne y
compris je pense que cette demande va
s'exprimer de plus en plus fort sur le
tourisme sur le tourisme responsable sur
le tourisme climatique et demain si le
tourisme est pas en phase avec les gens
je les enjeux du climat
il n'y aura plus de tourisme dans le
dans notre région il faut un tourisme
plus diffus un tourisme qui s'inscrit au
coeur au coeur des villages et -
peut-être de ski alpin et d'autres
d'autres activités c'est l'enjeu des cas
de saison jean sébastien lacroix le ski
alpin c'est dépassé ou faut déjà
réfléchir à l'après ça fait quand je
pense heures plusieurs années déjà qu'on
réfléchit à l'après éraillée grenade et
a mis en place des choses pour la prière
on investit pas uniquement dans le
scapin le scalp à nous permettent de
dégager des gains économiques ont
investi sur
sur du tourisme multi saisonniers on se
pose on se pose forcément les questions
de ce revirement de situation
moi ce que je crois surtout c'est que on
enterre quand même l'activité neige un
peu rapidement effectivement comme le
disait olivier on a quand même on a
quand même un petit peu je dirais une
période d'amortissement avant qu
effectivement des punaises dont vous
êtes d'accord avec olivier rare sur le
réseau des vingt ans on va attendre 25
ans nous rend actuellement sur station
des rousses on a on a un projet on a un
projet de liaison avec le massif de
l'hadopi et le massif voisin elle adore
les tu freines manqué c'est d'être en
cours d' enquête publique sur sur ses
investissements forcément on a fait des
prospectives pour pour pour voir si
effectivement il fallait il fallait pas
y aller en typiquement on nous annonce d
hiver qui seront à peu près les mêmes
qu'on a actuellement sur une quarantaine
d'années
ça fait déjà calme je dirais quelques
décennies qu'on a des hivers qui se
ressemblent pas commise et olivier et qu
il faut qu'on soit capable de passer les
mauvaises hiver il y aura des bons hiver
libre et un hiver des mauvaises hiver et
après c'est juste qu'il détecte ivement
il faut qu'on s'adapte assez tôt déficit
quels sont les enjeux économiques mais
nous rappeler combien vous fait
travailler deux personnes
directement et indirectement ce que
représentent les emplois saisonniers par
exemple nous offre là sur la station
durant la sogestar
on a bien sûr sur leur pleine période de
mode février on a à peu près 180
personnes qui travaillent qui travaille
dans l'entreprise
donc après c'est sûr si on ajoute à ça
les restaurants les logements les hôtels
etc
c'est sûr que ça fait beaucoup de
personnes actuellement il n'empêche que
les gens qui viennent encore sur la
station des rousses et sur métabief
également y viennent quand même en
priorité pour faire du ski donc
effectivement on a d'autres activités
qui viennent se greffer autour parce
qu'on investit sur d'autres choses
emma parce que pour l'instant encore
actuellement les gens y viennent sur les
stations pour faire du ski comme une
réaction de christian il nous a envoyé
un mail depuis le début de la semaine
les stations de moyenne montagne sont
sans doute condamné un faible
enneigement nous dit il y sera sans
doute nécessaire de changer l'avenir
commercial de la station lanchais pas
s'ils parlent de meet again ou des
rousses malheureusement précise-t-il
olivier rare ça tout le monde en a
conscience dans le milieu du ski alpin
bien entendu je rebondis sur la sur le
propos de monsieur poulin mais il faut
faire attention à pas plaquer à une
théorie sur ce que veulent les clients
ou sur ce que sur ce qui est aujourd'hui
le tourisme de notre montagne comme le
disait jean sébastien lacroix
les gens viennent chez nous d'abord pour
le ski le ski c'est 90% du chiffre
d'affaires d'une station on peut et on
le fait on diversifie
métabief le vtt on a fait foi deux en
l'espace de trois ans en terme de
fréquentation
c'est 10 % de notre chiffre d'affaires
on est l'une des stations en france qui
a lu la part la plus forte il faut il
faut bouger il faut changer les choses
on est et on est sûr c'est dynamique là
mais il ne faut pas imaginer qu'on fait
un oeil neuf et on serait mais
irresponsable de se tirer une balle dans
le pied aujourd'hui sur le ski alors
qu'on est encore en capacité d'en
assurer une viabilité et que les clients
viennent pour ça sans je peux être
d'accord sur le fait que c'est pas un
oeuf et c'est d'ailleurs tout le
discours des écologistes sur les phases
de transition écologique et énergétique
à une phase de transition mais dans
cette phase de transition
il faut pas entretenir un mythe autour
de la neige aujourd'hui non mais
aujourd'hui un canon à neige
maître de la neige de culture c'est
entretenir le mythe on peut qu'on peut
continuer sur les mêmes périodes
d'enneigement
aujourd'hui en effet il ya des périodes
de neige où on peut faire du ski et
s'arrêtant sur une activité économique
pour tous le pour tous deux massifs aux
gens à quel coût pour les collectivités
pour les impôts à quel coût
environnemental
lorsqu'on sait qu'une qu'un canot à
neige pour produire un hectare de canons
à neige c'est une piscine olympique doc
il faut à un moment on a on a vu on a vu
l'ensemble l'ensemble des l'ensemble on
va laisser répondre oliviera parce que
ça le fait sourire
on a d'ailleurs une question de monsieur
rare de sylvain quel est le bilan
écologique d'un canon à neige c'est une
vraie question que se posent les gens
souvent le bilan écologique la piscine
olympique leurs canons à neige nous on
appelle base à un canon à neige passé
c'est comme si on mettait la côte de
perlimpinpin au fond d'un canoë combats
lancés et qu' ils se posaient l'année
non c'est un nageur qui fait de l'eau et
de l'air aujourd'hui on a des
technologies d'enneigement qui risque
qui ont réduit considérablement
énergie la consommation d'eau et la
consommation d'air on il ya 1,8
il ya un mythe sur la neige de culture
il ya eu peut-être une un défaut de
communication de la profession moi je
suis moi je viens de l'environnement
j'étais responsable environnement
pendant 15 ans et je trouve que c'est
très facile de jeter la pierre sur la
neige de culture
tant qu'on n'a pas regardé comment ça
fonctionne et tant qu'on en a peu fait
le bilan est effectué en temps on est
sans doute en importe quoi sur la neige
de culture
alors que c'est c'est hyper iter gérer
de manière raisonnée de manière durable
où on a l'habitude de dire qu'à métabief
c'est 75% de l'activité alors de
recettes
mais ces 25 % de la couverture du
domaine siam est effectivement là à noël
nouvel an si on n'avait pas eu de neige
de culture
eh bien il ya eu personne et du coup à
quel coût depuis qu'on a fait la neige
de culture en 2013 l'écho les
contributions des collectivités ont été
réduites parce qu'on a fait une
augmentation de fréquentation on a un
taux de retour sur ces investissements
qui a fait rire à 12 ans c'est vous je
vous mets au défi de trouver un
investissement qui a un tel taux de
retour donc on est on est face à un
principe de réalité
on a des clients rivière réalité c'est
dire combien j'ai de ne pas entretenir
mais on a encore des plages de froid on
a de la technologie vertueuse qui nous
permet de faire un produit on a des
clients en face à ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas de faire un produit c'est pas
de faire le produit neymar 9 0c de
vendre la destination je conjure à je
trouve madian nature la destination
nature c'est le futur quand vous êtes
partout dans la région et que vous
vendez uniquement métabief à travers des
plaquettes qui montre des domaines
enneigées vous vendez en effet ce que
vous venez de dire le produit neige moi
ce que je souhaiterais demain c'est
qu'on vende notre territoire comme
quelque chose d'une destination nature à
garantir mais on va faire tourner la
parole pierre albert bordel j'aimerais
bien avoir votre
votre point de vue parce qu'on parle
beaucoup du ski alpin vous n'êtes plus
sur le ce qu'ils font avec la
transjurassienne le ski de fond qui a
aussi besoin d'enneigeurs ou canons à
neige pour reprendre le terme d' olivier
rats pour nous le premier constat c'est
coeur n'est pas responsable du climat du
réchauffement climatique
ça c'est une échelle beaucoup plus
importante que notre massif que notre
équipe de ski par contre toujours
stigmatisé comme des victimes comme les
responsables fiso finalement que ce
réchauffement climatique puisque on nous
a on nous donne toutes les tout les maux
du monde comme quoi on définir la nature
on fait des activités qu'ils ne sont pas
responsables à ce niveau là et puis pour
la plupart d'eux des gens qui qui vivent
sur ce secteur qui travaillent sur ces
secteurs ils auront ils ont leurs
racines ici ils ont toujours respecté
cette nature donc c'est vrai que c'est
ce débat car et la mutation des
blessures qu'on ne prépare la mutation
modem est responsable on en train de se
préparer avec avec la neige qui existe
une façon peut-être différente de la de
la garde et de la maintenir ya les bêtes
on voit qu'il ya des sous forme in qui
ce qui ce qui se prépare on peut on peut
utiliser moi c'est les chenaux farmine
c'est à dire que c'est à dire que c'est
le neige qui est qui aimait les fleurs
manège square des fermes à neige de
printemps à l'automne suivant
après on a effectivement ce problème par
rapport à l'aller jeu culture mais que
je sache
comme je viens de le dire olivier cette
neige de culture
elle se transforme en eau et elle repart
sur le versant en étant des gradients au
passage elle ne s'est pas leur genre et
décryptage
anthony poulin souligné a effectivement
un événement qui a fait polémique
il ya quelques mois c'est quand vous
avez à métabief tester les canons à
neige
alors que tout le département étaient en
vigilance sécheresse que la rivière le
doubs étaient à sec sur plusieurs
kilomètres est ce que vous comprenez
olivier rare que c'est plus choqué cette
image là des canons à neige qui sont
testés alors que la rivière juste à côté
est à sec
oui mais alors là on est tout à fait
conscient que ça va puer et c'est le
constat en fait du défaut des
communications qu'on a sur le principe
de gestion de notre de notre
installation qui n'avait rien à voir
avec l'arrêté sécheresse mais on peut
comprendre que d'un point de vue images
on comprenne pas celle que c'est de la
ressource en eau
c'est une ressource en eau de look est
prélevé à la fonte des neiges en avril
qui est stockée en altitude qui est
complètement isolé de tout réseau d'eau
potable ou de ressources naturelles donc
il ya aucun lien on est régi par un
arrêté préfectoral loi sur l'eau et
voilà donc nous on a bien compris que
nous en terme d'image mais on est on ne
regrette absolument pas d'avoir fait que
si on l'avait pas fait on n'aurait rien
fait jean sébastien lacroix sur cette
problématique de la ressource en eau
comment vous gérez south bon niveau de
leurs fonds sans doute comme des
oliviers effectivement les réserves on
les remplit est plutôt au printemps
quand quand quand quand la neige fond et
quand on a des forts épisodes pluvieux
après nos réserves et ne font pas cinq
cent mille mètres cubes non plus je
pense qu'effectivement il faut je pense
qu'il faut pas opposer écologie et puis
ce qui se passe avec noah nageurs et
avec la neige de culture parce que c'est
pas forcément incompatibles je crois
quand on travaille un petit peu avec les
différents services de l'état ils ont
bien compris qu'il ya des choses qui
sont faites il ya quelques années où
maintenant on a vraiment pris cette
habitude de raisonner environnement et
sacs investissements ça que chaque
donnée en fait tu prends vraiment qu'on
en compte cet investissement alors
justement sur le projet d'extension de
la station avec ce
ce raccordement au massif de la doll ça
a été reporté une première fois ça va se
faire finalement c'était reporter on a
dû faire des évaluations
environnementales et puis donc là je
vous dis on en phase d'enquêté publique
donc a priori si tout se passe bien les
travaux devraient démarrer cet été pour
une égalisation pour pour l'hiver
prochain
et c'est un investissement rentable
malgré les conditions d'enneigement
c'est bien sûr un glissement rentable
parce que on se lance pas dans ce genre
d'investissement à hauteur de 10
millions d'euros sans avoir une garantie
de rentabilité derrière donc hissé en
combien de temps c'est à voir c'est
cette norme et parce que ces territoires
parfois nous annonce des investissements
de ce type là avec des amorties
financier pendant de longues années sauf
qu'on constate que dans dix ans il ya
moins de neige est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
continuera à payer ces structures là
nous rendent à calais cet investissement
il y avait en fait on doit rentabiliser
sous 20 ans sous 20 ans donc dans 20 ans
potentiellement ya plus neige et on
continue à payer quelque chose qui
servaient uniquement pour cette finale
un temps à l'investissement sera
non payés parce que je vous dis qu'on me
this man sont prévus d'être remboursés
sous vingt ans après et c'est pouvoir
que ces investissements derrière qui
génère quand même beaucoup d beaucoup
d'économies qu on a beaucoup de demandes
des citoyens à travers différents
mouvements sur comment on utilise
l'argent comme on utilise l'argent
public est ce qu on arrive à faire à
faire face à toutes ces problématiques
là on nous annonce aujourd'hui qu'on va
faire un certain nombre
d'investissements qui sont rentabilisés
qui seront amortis dans ma temps alors
que on en a plus on aura plus cette
activité là dans 20 ans ouais il empêche
en attendant celle un temps pendant ce
temps là leur tour économiques pour les
collectivités il est il est certain qu
on fait on en sait pas de l'argent qui
est dépensé sans amour du retour ces
deux collectivités dont pierre albert ce
que je trouve dommage c'est que là ya
des toujours d'un débat d'opposition
entre eux par les deux de mes prix
respectifs entre les uns et les autres
nous on a connu ça je trouve qu'ils se
parlent de manière de façon plus
générale
donc nous on a connu effectivement cette
ce clivage il ya quelques années donc
ils aient été résolus comment part de la
collaboration actuellement on travaille
avec qui le groupe jura tetra travail et
que le pnr on travaillait clé de reals
pour trouver des solution qui satisfasse
tout le monde
et puis je pense que ces solutions peut
les trouver en bonne intelligence en bon
sens et élites et de faire ce clivage
entre les horizons parce que parce que
c'est déplorable
il ya la même problématique que pour la
doll avec les routes chez vous avec
picabia tiens il ya un projet
d'extension
du domaine est ce qui va se faire
prenant en compte les conditions
d'enneigement des années à venir alors
merci de me poser la question parce que
justement c'est on est innovant âme est
abyssal et en site pilote au niveau
français pour développer une méthode de
restructuration des remontées mécaniques
existantes
donc notre politique elle est
complètement durable d'ailleurs on a on
a été évalué par un indicateur qui
s'appelle guillaume et on et 73 % de nos
dépenses contribuer au développement
durable local le btp c'est 30% la grande
distribution c'est 20 % la moyenne des
domaines skiables ses 60%
c'est pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur a donc sur pick les petits dés
c'est effectivement le réemploi me fais
de l'éco-conception et on est dans cette
logique vraiment de durabilité de nos
installations pour qu'effectivement le
jour on est plus neige en les démonte
elles sont amortis depuis très très
longtemps on n'a aucun traumatisme
budgétaire on a une vraie gestion de la
dette par les 10 millions à peu près
pour la doll l'etuf vous pique bien tard
à peine plus je crois pas du tout non
c'est combien pas du tout j'ai lu 13
millions c'est pas ça on en alu 17 on a
eu 24 avaient leurs aînés au cours du
chiffrage mais une restructuration d'une
remontée
c'est de l'ordre d'un million là on aura
je sais pas on va être peut-être autour
de 3,4 ah oui c'est pas du 5 ou 6 quai
par la brèche à jamais non parce qu'on
arrive au terme de l'émission vous nous
avez parlé tout à l'heure du projet vtt
qui fonctionnait bien
c'est quoi une station quatre saisons
comment on fait pour développer le
tourisme
toute l'année on va dire sur des
stations de sports d'hiver alors le
autant une station l'hiver elle capte la
majeure partie la fréquentation sur un
sur un territoire les tcc diffus
un opérateurs de remontées mécaniques
pour tirer son épingle du jeu l'été
c'est plus compliqué non on a misé sur
la pluriactivité de nos remontées
mécaniques
on en a deux qui sont utilisés été hiver
voit les images c'est magnifique un
métal précieux
l'enjeu l'enjeu est on est ouvert 90
jours l'été 90 jours l'hiver on est une
vraie station annuels en termes de
remontée mécanique
comment on fait en bas c'est d'abord les
métiers je reviens et celles à savoir
faire de tracer des pistes et ça paraît
évident de développer l'été mais c'est
pas non plus très évident par rapport
aux contraintes environnementales
également et je m'inscris en faux par
rapport à ce qui s'était dit il ya
autant de communication d'ailleurs le
chiffre d'affaires global du territoire
il est équivalent l'hiver que l'été et
la communication et les équivalente
donc pourquoi on irait allait se tirer
une balle dans le pied et l'hiver alors
qu'on sait faire les deux aujourd'hui il
en est dense et on est prêts à la
transition
nous on n'est pas inquiet on ne s'est
pas fait renoncer sans neige industriel
or entre temps jean sébastien lacroix on
met assez en avant aussi les richesses
du territoire l'été parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a un super massifs très important
les gens y viennent l'été c'est surtout
pour ça effectivement on est du coup on
rentre dans un champ concurrentiel qui
est plus grands effectivement mais les
gens qui viennent l'été chez nous ils
viennent pour l'épisode ils viennent
pour trouver 7-16 cette âme soeur delà
de la nature et puis savoir toujours
activement on développe sur des
activités estivales mais ça reste
anecdotique ou c'est vraiment une
priorité pour vous aussi
c'est ainsi je dirais que c'est pareil
c'est pas une priorité mais c'est aussi
un pied d'égalité que ce qu'on fait
libéreront je pense que l'on sait qu'il
était très important où d'aucuns la
chance d'avoir des stations qui y vivent
toute l'année
ce concept est habillée c'est la même
chose on n'a pas des coups décisifs qui
sont très marquées entre l'hiver l'été
et puis le reste du temps où il ya
personne dans nos stations on a des
stations qui en vivent toute l'année
donc réputés mans tout et à tout et
infrastructures sur lesquels on investit
cd1 structure garçon qui sert toute la
nuit et effectivement merci à tous les
quatre c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission je pense qu'on aurait pu faire
une heure de plus pour ce débat merci
d'être venu ici à chaux neuve pour cette
émission spéciale à l'occasion de la
coupe du monde de ski nordique vous
pourrez suivre la fin de la compétition
à partir de 13h30 sur internet avec
clément jallet et sylvain guillaume
dans un instant dimanche en politique
continue avec francis letellier qui
reçoit gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics profitez
bien de votre après-midi et vib la
montagne en été comme en hiver
[Musique]
je suis un jeu